نحن الان في منطقتي بروفايل شرق كياف حيث
تحطمت صباحا طائره مروحيه تابعه لخدمه
الطوارئ الحكوميه بحسب ما افادت السلطات
الاوكرانيه فان هذا الحادثه ادى الى مقتل
وزير الداخليه
وانائبه الاول وكذلك وزير دوله في الحكومه
الاوكرانيه كانوا علمتني هذه المروحيه وهي
تحطمت وسط منطقه سكنيه تضم كذلك روضه
اطفال لذلك افيد عن عددا كبير من القتل
نتيجه هذا الحادث بينهم اطفال بالاضافه
الى حوالي 29 جريحا ايضا تم نقلهم الى
المستشفيات والحصيات ومرشحه للارتفاع على
سيامه وان فرق الاسعاف والطوارئ التي هرعت
الى مكان الحادث ما زالت تعمل على اجلاء
الضحايا
السلطات الاوكرانيه لم تفرد عن معلومات
رسميه حول سبب سقوط هذه المروحيه
والتحطمها ولكنها طلبت من شهود عيان كانوا
موجودين في المنطقه اثناء حصول الحادث
الاتصال فورا بالشرطه لتوضيح ملابسات ما
جرى لاسيما وان بعض الشهور تحدث عن انهم
سمعوا صوت المروحيه وهي تسقط قبل تحطمها
وارتطامها
بالمبنى ولم يفرض حتى هذه اللحظه عن اي
معلومات رسميه تفيد بان المروحيه تعرضت
لاي عمل غذائيا قد يكون متسبب بهذا الحادث
من منطقه بروفايل شرقا كاف كاترين حنا
الجزيره